hallo ich meiner lieben freund will
kommt zu einer solo battle rund ich
mache das ganze zum ersten mal mit luke
place cartel media ckd um gespielt und
zu einem server
das wird alles so ablaufen dass wir 20
minuten hat jeder für sich jeder kämpft
alleine hat jeder für sich zahlt sich
sachen abzufahren sich nicht eine
rüstung zu wahren und irgendwann im chat
steht dann pvp und da müssen uns alle
gegenseitig nieder glocken und ja ich
versuche das einfach mal eben nicht als
letzter zu bestreiten und irgendwie ein
bisschen defensiver vorzugehen die map
ist keine extra generierte map für sonst
für so ein battle und im chat steht
jetzt in 30 sekunden noch bis zum start
die versuche ich das nur ganz kurz
bisschen näher zu bringen ich habe mich
jetzt noch ein bisschen informiert wo
ich ja lauf also gleich für diese
plattform hier wahrscheinlich einfach
weggehen wir werden runterfallen links
und wasser sehr wahrscheinlich werden in
alle richtungen laufen wir also ich
denke ich werde erstmal den lauf auf ich
denke ich werde da hinten irgendwo hin
laufen da hinten sind ganz ganz viele
höhlen elterlicher mal schon sachen okay
gut
ich weiß zwar nicht vorher so dass
hamburg wieder halb tot ich bin
wahrscheinlich eh gleich schon tot so
ich hätte es mir hätten laufen ganz
einfach damit eventuell irgendwie holz
kriegen da hinten ist auf jeden fall
schon mal holz und ich versuche auf
jeden fall mein ziel ist es nicht letzte
zu werden weil ich das ganze hier zuerst
mal spiele und ja wie schon gesagt beim
20 minuten friedens phase und ja wie
auch schon gesagt bitte nicht meckern
wenn ich jetzt relativ schnell fakten
werde ich weiß nicht ob das ganze ein
video hochladen werde ich glaube ja zwei
runden zwei videos einmal die friedens
phase als ein video und danach noch mal
die game runde dann
er ist hat er meine sticks oder wie
lediglich nicht weil sie nicht auch sehr
unglücklich dass man die gleiche
richtung läuft wie ich so cartel media
schreibt er das okay was so roland
nehmen jetzt mal ganz schnell wieder mit
nicht dass der luchs ich davon irgendwie
noch nutzen macht so und jetzt erstmal
da hinten da war irgendwo so eine kiste
oder eine höhle ja genau die höhle war
hier das ist keine höhle rehbaum dass
mich ein bisschen steigern
ich weiß schon dass ich nachher
hundertprozentig wieder der schlechteste
sein werde so jetzt habe ich eine stein
dingens stein schwert noch ein stein
schwert und noch eine stein spitzhacke
so 123 123 haben jetzt geht jetzt gar
nicht gut da muss man mal ein paar
tricks machen so 12 sollte reichen so
noch eine spitzhacke
schwerdt schwert da hinten ist soll halo
wars ist 30 immer noch nicht cadel media
widmet er war so verdient würde die am
ende wird erstmal von slade
abgeschalteter weise klar einfach nur
ich muss schauen dass ich jetzt irgendwo
eine höhle finde das sieht nicht nach
einer höhle aus vielleicht ist er
trotzdem irgendwas dran nee das nix drin
damit wir irgendwie an eisen kommen oder
so und umrüstung bzw schwert finde ich
eigentlich erst mal nicht ganz so da
oben ist kohle das ist schon mal gut
schwert finde ich erst mal nicht ganz so
wichtig scheiße viel wichtiger finde ich
eigentlich bisher erst mal eine rüstung
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen soll dass
cola
ich höre die ganze zeit spinnen okay gut
da unten
warum es auch noch kohle meine waffe
baue ich gerade kohle habt wenn ich dir
ähnlich brauche wenn ich kein eisen okay
gut wir werden gleich einfach da unten
ist allerdings nach ja wir brauchen ja
kohle für fackeln fällt mir gerade auch
so auf komm her komm her kohle brave
kohle war hier noch ein bisschen erde
einfach so falls ich mich ein grund
haben will
das nehme ich ihm natürlich damit was
ein bisschen rum graben kann ja nicht
schaden
sodann wollte ich mir noch das machen
eine schaufel und fackeln den ort nicht
das ganze jetzt mal so ein bisschen an
so dass hinzu sachen die mich erstmal
nur umbauen möchten möchte würde ich
nehme ich einfach mal wieder mit das ist
blöd wenn die sachen wenn man das da
unten wechselt das dann immer die der
fortschritt im block weggeht alter das
ist aber krass vielarbeiter krass viele
jobs recht auf die meisten greifen sich
doch nicht gerade selber an
ich warte einfach mal auf die spinne das
sieht dann wieder hier oben ist da unten
jetzt raus sehe ich gerade soll dies tut
so etwas
entschuldigung hast du die maps sogar
abgegrenzt sich da gerade am rand aber
ganz noch eine glaskuppel jetzt colo
colo colo
er ist nicht immer wieder mit ich weiß
ja nicht wie
wichtig das alles hier ist also wie
wichtig fackel nachher sind im battle
ich glaube er gar nicht wichtig glaubt
es auch relativ dumm dass ich mich
eigentlich die gerade die ganze kohle
mitnehmen wollte eigentlich viel mehr
aufweisen suche gehen und zwar mache ich
das jetzt ganz einfach mal in dem ich
hier f3 drücke mich auf eine höhere
untergrabe die relativ tief ist aber da
ich mit 60 anfang erstmal ein bisschen
tiefer in eine tiefere region komme ich
bin ja auch so eine fackel auf
sonnenberg rum und trat mich deine in
boden rein so was haben wir denn hier
alles nummer der staat da oben war
bestimmt eine gute höhe um irgendwie
keine ahnung was zu finden an rohstoffen
was bewegt dass mannschaft aber auch
irgendwie angst dass teile ich frage
mich für die ganzen anderen sind ich
meine jetzt keiner meiner nähe ist das
erste mal dass ich irgendwie so ein
battle dingsbums ihr mitspieler
doch da unten ist ein grad gewesen da
unten ist einer da unten baut gerade
einer was ab da muss ich jetzt noch
irgendwo hinkommen dies sind die engel
kommen frage ich nicht gerade so dass
eisen also schon mal gut
nehmen wir 22 14 also es gab 21 50 22 5
meint mein zimmer und gerade weil sie
nicht will ich muss mich erst mal darum
kümmern dass ich hier so ein bisschen an
sachen komme ich mir fällt auch gerade
auf ich brauche ein bisschen was zu
fressen
als die fräsen ich dass ich hier gleich
noch ein verrecken bin hier bin ich
gerade schon aber in level 2 und ist ein
zombie sieht so aus das war hier unten
schon niemand mehr oder oder oder oder
nee da unten sitzt noch immer tief frei
aus ich habe aber trotzdem gerade ein
bisschen angst
hallo nobs reisen heißt es gut als ist
immer gut jetzt sagen aus eisen rutschen
wir uns jetzt gleich erstmal was wenn
ich noch nicht noch ein bisschen mehr
finde das natürlich sehr sehr optimal
wäre jeder und es nichts mehr ich war
aber schon wieder spinnen nicht so geil
ich brauche definitiv erst mal irgendwas
zu essen gleich oder schmiedeeisen das
gut man männer haben maushake menschen
einfach so das liegt einfach daran dass
mein pc so derbe kacke ist so ich mache
das jetzt einfach mal ich habe hier
schon so ein paar fürs protokoll sobald
im pvp zählen alle tote und keine diaz
mehr abbauen
ok alle tode verstehe ich jetzt gerade
nicht ganz so ich nehme doch mal ein
bisschen merkur oder mit ich weiß ja
nicht wie viel kohle das immer so
braucht und mit lava und alles lasse ich
mir einfach so ein lava einmal machen
mit den mann hinterm ich setze mich
einer verfolgt sei bestimmt irgendwie
sind voll
ich mag keine angst dass die ganzen
anderen schon irgendwie kias haben und
so das kabel soll man lieber weggehen
gerade geweckt
hier kann können die mir auch sachen
klang eigentlich frage ich mich quasi
der fällt einfach runter so jetzt erst
mal das wichtigste ich habe keine
kleinen kein holz mehr empfinden drauf
ich glaube man darf sachen clown oder
aber ich bin mir nicht sicher
ich kann einfach mal nachschauen was der
da unten so hat
das ist ganz okay ich es erstmal was es
war kaka was ich mir grad angepfiffen
habe aber so kommen jetzt rutschen hier
runter ich kann ja schon mal mitnehmen
ach ich bin so dumm
so sehen wir das ding wird jetzt muss
ich mich erst mal ein bisschen was zu
fressen kümmern was zu fressen
ich hoffe nur dass hier nicht tag und
nacht links ist egal hauptsache ich
bleib wach bis die wolken wieder lieder
sind ja ich glaube es ist nacht wenn ich
rausgehe
mehr ist nicht ich habe trotzdem gerade
irgendwie angst brauche jetzt irgendwas
zu machen
man wird kann ich denn hier essen bei
seiner mittel ohne witz hat kann ich
denn ihr essen meinte hey ich finde ja
nix gehen jetzt davon aus dass ich mir
jetzt weisen irgendwie was an be oder
wie immer schauen vielleicht ist in der
umgebung was neues nicht dass kohle
hier steht eine workbench
was macht die denn hier ich glaube ich
einfach mal mit ich glaube ich bin hier
total fürsorglich und geht total
defensiv vor beziehungsweise in dem
alles mit was ich irgendwie hab oder so
ich glaube ich nicht gut wissen nicht
gut managen nicht gut euro mehrere
creeper so oft ich wollte mir holz wurde
dann so sachen machen weist man brauche
auch noch fleisch wie komme ich da jetzt
runter
hier vielleicht
wäre ja auch nicht naja sollen wir
erstmal egal sein
ich bin so dumm so hallo gibt mehr holz
ist denn hier heute hier ist echt erbe
wenig holz fällt mir geradezu auf hinten
steht ein baum das auge kommt es mir
erst mal ein bisschen näher
hier sind auch ich gar keine schweine
wenig zu essen
wir setzen nicht ob das jetzt ein
totaler mit spruch war weil das so das
hauptproblem ist wenn sie so was aber
also nicht ich denke ich werde mich am
anfang erstmal nicht verstecken aber auf
jeden fall weiter herumlaufen bisschen
rum gucken was es sonst noch so zu
entdecken gibt ja noch so ist
wahrscheinlich auch ein problem von der
bin ich nicht so ganz der kategorie
sofort wieder pannen an dem baum nicht
ganz abgestellt
was gibt her ich brauche eine zwei oder
vielleicht noch mehr ich weiß nicht ich
nehme ich auch noch mit ich nehme ich
auch noch mit ich auch noch das holz so
brauche sticks
so
so eine brust platte für mich erst mal
wichtig
nämlich dass man damit und begeht nicht
auf die suche nach irgendetwas essbaren
er wird nämlich kein bock auf der farm
anzulegen jetzt vor genau acht minuten
noch das bringt nicht immer nur noch
eine von diesen 100 keulen also ich weiß
nicht wie oft ihr habt also ob ich dann
in die komplett sterben auf die hälfte
runter gehe ich werde doch auch nicht
stirbt man wenn die keulen weg sind wir
sind echt nur schaffen wenn wat wird
bringt das ok darf man in der
wechselphase blöcke setzen ja sorry
leute dass ich jetzt hier soviel frage
fest dass seine erste von komischen
battles die ich mit spiel ich hab das
noch mal gesehen und wollte dass man
immer machen klar klar weiß ich bin
kaputt
okay hier sieht aus als
nutze ich selbst etwas zu essen das war
auf jeden fall schon mal da geht es noch
mal rein
ich hasse dieses komische blubbernde
zeugs hier geht's weiter
das sind immerhin geht es wahrscheinlich
noch mal weiter besten es echt gewesen
wenn ich mir so eine komische eisen
spitzhacke gemacht hätte letztlich ganz
anders werden ihnen diese über mir herr
oder links von mir die das hört sich so
an als wenn die über mir naja leute ich
hab genug pfeile ich hab's ja vorhin
schon gesagt das machen werde
55 sind wir gerade auf gott nein
und wir haben noch genau fünf minuten
zeit so lange werden wir wahrscheinlich
brauchen bisher 1 unten sind so und
genau deswegen mache ich jetzt mal kurz
so kurz warten wir ein bisschen weiter
untergraben
na toll und zwar mache ich mir nun eine
eisen spitzhacke damit einfach ein
bisschen schneller geht
ich glaube ich war einfach einfach viel
zu langsam ich hab da kohle mitgenommen
als mögliche wir müssen uns erst mal um
die wichtigen sachen kümmern danach kann
man sich die die leichten sachen abholen
keine ahnung wie lange dauert das jetzt
hier noch zwei drei platzieren wir da so
ein crafting table 23
kommt mit
achja fackeln brauch noch 'n ein dass du
die ganze kohle drin
ich werde doch eh so verpacken es ist
doch schon vorprogrammiert
halo charaktervoll pessimistisch
ich möchte irgendwelche coolen sachen
finden kommen hier so packend für euch
zur beleuchtung des weges und chip
direkt vor mir ist und dann schon so da
unten das sind schon ganz viele sachen
gefunden hat dabei heftig ich höre auch
schon lava der freude erweckend loop
label def geil
das heißt dann den ganzen sachen sind
jetzt wahrscheinlich vorbei denn jolo
weil ein lava gefallen ist oder so kam
mir natürlich auch passieren dass heißt
ich soll mich selbst lieber nicht zu
früh freuen
kann ja immer mal passieren dass man
noch dachte ich muss ihn laufen laufen
wenn ich auch und wenn ich aber sehe
dann muss ich ihn laufen
ich hasse griffel
nein ich bin zu tun
zur 17 16 15
52 dieser die passende höhe für ähnliche
diamanten oder nicht nur grob schätzen
was finde ich love is cool
verhältnissen name irgendwer keine
ahnung lu place glaube ich so weit ich
jetzt mal die richtung keinen bock auf
erde bauen emerald cool
danke für den emerald aber kann ich
wenig mitmachen
das wäre es wenn jetzt hier im dorf wer
oder so natürlich geil könnte ich daher
mit den leuten bisschen handeln wir so
diamanten raus sondern und so hieß der
wie es läuft man das jetzt echt genial
wenn ich jetzt noch in diamanten finden
würde oder zwei am besten aber diesen
treten ja auch zu zweit auf einer wird
man rein gar nichts bringen 22 wird drei
gar nicht mehr allzu viel zeit
okay noch reisen jeden fall schon mal
etwas
irgendwas geil es jetzt über links und
rechts wasser skelette da ist eine welle
wo fakt da habe ich mich erst mal direkt
in seine höhle rein kommt der sommer
hier runter
es war heftig braucht definitiv
irgendwas fressen oder so jetzt bin ich
hier direkt dauern
meine norris no fun
ich meine ich brauche was zu fressen
sonst habe ich direkt verkauft gold kann
ja nix anfangen
warum ist noch alles wollte ich mir noch
eben dann will ich sagen
revel alter
ok ich hab hier keiner
jetzt muss ich noch aus der höhle raus
wenn man die asynchronen findet das sind
rund acht tagen die cloud oder irgendwie
so keine ahnung dass außer den oben
gehandelt
wer sich nicht ich stehe kurz davor
alter nehme ich wusste gleich dass man
sachen clown darf wenn die da jetzt
wieder eine rausnimmt l
diese sagt mir das keiner man das weil
ich da frag ich hatte da noch derbe viel
eisen drin wo man es richtig ungünstig
um jetzt gibt er hier
wieso kann ich echt schnell
es liegt hier auf dem feld ihr dass
irgendwas sachsen auf meinem boden
liebherr in ordnung jetzt kommen
letzter ich habe direkt verklagt weil
ich einfach weil ich so was können jetzt
aus fünf überhaupt noch machen
helm es wird darauf hinauslaufen dass
ich crafting table b2b darauf
hinauslaufen dass verpacken werde wenn
wir da so ein typ das um gespielt
darf man es nieten
ich weiß nicht wenn ich's nickel sieht
er mich dann als wenn ich es nico und
springe um gespielt hat bestimmt schon
richtig geile sachen
müsse was würde ich jetzt einfach
nahkampf wenn ich jetzt packe dann lade
ich auch als komplettes video hoch und
ich mache mir schon mal so einen geilen
auf weg damit ich das nur zwei hoch
voller angst ist jetzt richtig gut
ausgerüstet ist und mit der bauhaus
ich weiß nicht was passiert wohl wenn
ich ihn doch jetzt in der höhle töte
ich bin mir gerade nicht so sicher das
überhaupt erlaubt es der mich
hundertprozentig gesehen
sonst wird er da nicht so davon zu
nicken
jetzt einfach mal vielleicht läuft ja
hierher so da unten da unten habe ich
dann gesehen da unten war name
darunter 100 prozentig name das nicht
irgendeiner unter mir aber kein plan
wohnt keinen plan b und ich hab so was
von wenig herzen dass ich mich nicht
traue danach zu gucken
da sind alle lassen name dass ein name
setzte jetzt einfach mal blöcke hin
ja das ist um gespielt dass es um
gespielt jeder läuft weg dann läuft
jetzt auch mal weg an die oberfläche
vielleicht ist er auch von einer
komplett anderen seite rein gegangen als
ich das kann natürlich auch sein
da steht ein zombie die können eventuell
noch ein bisschen schönes leckeres
fleisch geben da habe ich schon mal
bisschen fleisch
hier ist zwar noch ein zombie guter
letzt mit direkt zwei fallen muss
trotzdem irgendwie noch ein bisschen an
fleisch kommen
galt hessens ponor geilmann wieder ist
das denn
geil geil geil geil geil krass alter das
ist genau das was jetzt gebraucht habe
so entscheide des book wie kann ich das
jetzt anwenden
nach fakt dafür bräuchten komischen die
hessen die teile amboss amboss minecraft
wiki vier eisen und eisen bühler
dafür brauche ich so viele sachen ein
das ziel kann ich jetzt gar nicht
gebrauchen oder wie frame eins verdammt
teuer ist bringt jetzt auch nichts mehr
wenigstens ein bisschen ovid drei brote
schon mal ganz geil
sodann letztes mal mein leben ein
bisschen auf hat erst einmal mit auch
ich verstehe minecraft langsam echt
nicht mehr ist als ein fach mit
aufgefressen
ich hab sattel ich habe im emerald
hoeneß für eines fensters ich habe noch
ein eisen weil da drin war sollte jetzt
einfach mit inventar man solchen der
sortieren dass er nichts großartig zu
sortieren
der gleichen league ist jetzt mal wieder
mit auf jeden fall cool dass ich jetzt
ein bisschen was zu fressen gefunden
habe und das heißt ja schon mal dass ich
das in dieser höhle noch keiner wahr
wenn die jetzt noch keine entdeckt hat
dann darf man noch
ich dachte wir einnahmen gekoppelt storm
blog alter da war mein herz aber
quatschen dem rasen ok also darf man
noch meint er gerade fällt oder eine
explosion der rechts glätte wenn der
leute tnt oder so haben dann bitte ich
ja mal ganz schön am arsch
eigentlich ja die ganze zeit explosionen
kein plan warum
das empfehle ich weiß nicht wo leute
sind ich suche die ganze zeit schon
irgendwas anderes als mal wölfe schafe
und diesen ganzen krepler ich suche ja
ich suche ich nein ich suche ja sachen
die ich fressen kann
butt ich packe jetzt immer in einer hier
hatte ich einfach mal wasser rein weil
wenn ich dann vor ihm weglaufen kann ich
leider einfach wasser hinsetzen wird
also zurück geschwemmte nicht nach vorne
geschwemmt nicht als auch hinten setzen
versteht ihr wenn ihr natürlich nicht so
bei pv peking ich habe keine ahnung
welche taktik ich am besten verwenden
sollte aber das kann ja noch werden
pvp ging wird wohl sehr schwer das auch
nicht wie meine minecraft oder pvp king
sein kann wenn man da einfach nur auf
den knopf drücken muss er ist das nicht
aber ich meine so allgemein mit
praktiken ausdenken da ist er gerade
ränder fehler ich habe keinen plan warum
ich hoffe jetzt dass hier irgendwo jetzt
vielleicht noch ein bisschen was zu
essen
jetzt noch eine höhle waren auch schon
welche drin ich weiß es nicht ich glaube
nicht sonst wäre schön ausgeleuchtet
hallo
ich war hier schon jemand also die manie
reisen darf noch ab und ist ja in höhlen
kohle bringt jetzt auch nichts mehr
ich glaube ich dass mein fehler war
wirklich dass ich am anfang viel zu
vorsichtig war sage ich mal
weil ich mir erstmal crafting tae
bildern habe ich die clean crafting
table mitgenommen als ich jetzt auch
einfach stehen lassen können ich sage es
mal so ich könnte ja mal probieren
erst jetzt kommt klettern
jetzt können wir eventuell zusammen auf
einen drauf gehen solche ritzen hund im
januar bestimmt nicht okay das ist ein
fetter berg vor uns und wissen typ der
doch schon alle möglichen sachen aber
ich habe ein hund
erst mal ganz kurz meinen
da hinten gespielt
für mich irgendwo verstecken kommission
kommt
age ob ein hund hier im weg entschieden
verhältnis nun gespielt ich weiß nicht
was der da hinten baut kein plan mein
herz uns am rasen
wer sich von dieser welt von einer
anderen seite probieren kommen wir
versuchen diejenigen die wieder
runterzukommen
ich bin schon irgendwie zurückgeblieben
ich rede mit meinem hund lustvoll stars
grit einfach direkt ins hohe ecke auf
ich kenne einfach versuchen nämlich von
unten rein zu graben ist nicht
funktioniert auch nicht
wann diese macht man auch wieso macht
mein hund nichts
mein hund hat einfach nicht gekämpft nur
das packe ja cool wenn er da oben die
ganze zeit herumsteht und kämmt
herumgespielt leiste spaß also freunde
das was bei mir mit dem virtual ich lad
das ganze als eine folge hoch dann habt
ihr 30 minuten und war müssen das hier
hallo
keine ahnung was es ist achso ungespielt
acht euro nein natürlich als ein spaß
war auf das mesh kraft superkraft bros
brawl bezogen also vielen dank dass er
zugeschaut habe ich war wie schon gesagt
er ist gestorben
wie schon gesagt war ich wahrscheinlich
jetzt habe ich aber schon am anfang sagt
weiß das erste ist was mit gemacht habe
ich habe die priorität natürlich nicht
so toll gesetzt und hätte ganz am anfang
einfach auf kukksi hat sich einer doch
weizen angepflanzt hat man sein hätte
wahrscheinlich nicht ganz am anfang auf
dings gehen sollen
es wurden hier gebaut auf so höre euch
mit dem ex crafting table und dass alles
so bleibt sondern wirklich mehr soja
diamanten etc etc
das sieht auf jeden fall schauen also
sehr geil aus das haus naja gut freunde
wenn es euch gefallen da oben ist auch
eine map so dass es wahrscheinlich ein
neues ein altes links gelesen wo die
davor gespielt haben wenn es euch
gefallen hat könnt ihr einen daumen hoch
geben wenn ihr mehr wollt sonst könnt
ihr einfach mal eure meinung wie ihr
sowas findet in den kommentaren lassen
wird mich auf jeden fall freuen und auch
interessieren
und dann sehen wir uns eventuell wieder
in solchen battle aufnahmen oder jetzt
allgemein mehr so travel am main will
hunger games superkraft bros brawl
venture maps etc pp